hey hey look at me
now the one thing i hate when they do
movies is every time you get some sort
of torso injuries they make them spit
blood and that doesn't happen you don't
vomit blood from getting a gut shot or
anything like that hi my name is peter
ree i served in the military for 24
years
and i'm a trauma surgeon i was one of
the first surgeons in the afghanistan
today we're going to be looking at
battle wound scenes in movies and
judging how real they are
[Applause]
this is a really good scene when that
explosion went off in slow motion you
could see the boot flying right at the
camera it's a little bit unusual from an
injury point of view a shell coming in
hitting the ground would take his legs
off like that because that seeing
bilateral amputees at the thigh has been
a really recent injury that we never saw
before in previous wars we didn't really
see bilateral amputations above the knee
before the other war movies they would
step on claymores and land mines and
those were actually meant to take off
your foot and your ankle
so the medics would come out and then
you'd sniper the medics and get more
casualties so it wasn't really supposed
to be a mortal wound his was mangled
below the knee but obviously his was
going to be close to what we were seeing
in iraq where they would just build
these huge bombs and bury them into the
ground we were seeing just legs blown
sky-high
i could do three hours on tourniquets
blood loss is the number one preventable
loss that we want to avoid some of the
soldiers they even wear tourniquets when
they're going out there actually what we
are recommending and what we teach is
that they put on your own tourniquets
the tourniquets are
problematic because if you don't put it
on right and if it's not on absolutely
the tightest it can be you'll bleed more
and you'll bleed out when you put it on
you got to commit to it you got to go
full bore and i tell you putting a
tourniquet on will be the most painful
thing you experienced about three to
four minutes it's like your leg is
falling off so it is something you do as
a last resort it will save lives but you
got to go for it otherwise it will
actually bleed more
here comes the morphing here comes the
morphine it's going to kick in real
quick bro we're going to get you shifted
in the old days morphine was good we got
scared of it because morphine can
definitely kill you if you take a person
who's low blood pressure not a blood
circulating and then you give it then it
can depress your or your cardiac
function and then you can die you would
also stop breathing so we've actually
gone away from morphine in the field we
use a new drug called ketamine while it
provides a lot of relief of pain it does
not lower your blood pressure so that's
the reason why we use it the medics can
do a lot and they're so vitally
important but a lot of the movies
is i think the audience doesn't
understand that a medic is not a trauma
surgeon trauma surgeon obviously went to
medical school
did
five years of general surgery then two
years of training as a trauma surgeon so
seven years of training like a brain
surgeon the medic's job is to get them
to us
not to clamp things in the field it's
pretty good i'd say give it a nine
now we know that iv bags actually hurt
you we no longer use crystalloid
solutions in trauma even when your blood
pressure falls the studies that we've
shown is that the people who don't get
those iv bags they have a better chance
of surviving
if you give them
that fluid their blood pressure goes up
and then you bleed more back then that
was the only way we did it we are only
finally recognizing that salt water
solution doesn't resemble blood at all
three
[Music]
i think he put a mosquito clamp in the
mouth to do it that was turning me off a
little bit i could see it doing it with
bare hands as a possibility we used to
do a lot of this in bare hands and when
i started my residency we were doing it
bare hands too so that's not too
unrealistic that area is called a
junctional bleed
where you can't put a tourniquet on it
so we're still trying to invent ways to
stop bleeding when you get shot at the
groin or in the armpit because you can't
put a tourniquet into your armpit
oh i got it no doc
this was not a good scene for me i've
used it for training lots of times the
way they did the artery clamping the
artery and so on for surgeons and people
who do vascular surgery and it wasn't
very realistic it is somewhat chaotic
obviously somebody had a flashlight on
there that's the reason why we always
wear headlights on our head for the
trauma out there you don't need much you
just need some basic retractors you got
to have good lighting and then the
second thing is you gotta have suction
if you don't have suction nowadays it's
really tough just working with sponges
and ways to soak up stuff for what what
i do you don't need a lot of stuff so
that is a major problem the wounds were
okay i'd give this about a six i expect
it
priority
he's gone
it's a great movie it's it's pretty well
done triage in the field is very
different than triage when you come to a
medical company you're not doing so much
of this actually during the heat of the
battle itself it's usually once the
initial fire fight gets done there's
four categories when we triage so he
went through all four of them dead
expectant they need your help and then
they're okay the guy's hollering and
yelling if they're yelling they're okay
so it's a routine and then then he had
one guy that's a priority and then the
guy was already dead confirming someone
that's dead in a few seconds is not easy
to do i was in ramadi when we had a 200
people that were bombed at one time from
one bomb we got 70 of these casualties
that came right to us
just coming in and they all come in one
by one and i was the triage officer the
first marine i got was expecting but but
i couldn't tell for sure because i only
had literally four or five seconds to
decide whether he was dead or not and
there was no way we could use our
resources to work on them so what you're
doing is trying to cherry pick the easy
saves so you don't want to spend too
much time on it which is very different
than what we do
in civilian trauma in civilian trauma we
go full bore hardcore team of 12 on top
of one person for hours and hours and
that's not something you can do in the
military i'd give it a 9.
[Applause]
what they're trying to show is an
evisceration so a guy got hit they're
taking enemy fire high velocity weapons
ak-47s out there getting hit and then
you eviscerate your organs they're
making an attempt to push it back and
you can't do it it doesn't work that way
the ones i saw were from exit wounds of
ak-47s through a little small plum-sized
hole you will shove everything out
because you got pressure as you're
grunting and moaning from the pain
and then you can't shove it back in
because it just pops right back out so
unless they're
chemically paralyzed by intubating them
it's a waste of time in penetrating
injury when we're talking about
bullet wounds and so on like that the
main thing is just get them to me as
soon as you can and stop the bleeding if
it's not your heart and your major
vessels we can save you if you don't hit
those the rest we can repair hey hey
look at me
now the one thing i hate when they do
movies is every time you get some sort
of torso injuries they make them spit
blood and that doesn't happen
unless you get shot in the mouth or you
have something going through your cheeks
and your throat up high you don't vomit
blood from getting a gut shot or
anything like that
[Music]
the one thing i do like is they do show
how difficult it is to move a heavy body
out there these are two to three hundred
pound
masses that you gotta drag and two guys
pulling these things is not that easy to
do i think that part's all done
you never drop in a bird when there's
fire going on and a bird's not going to
come down to go do a casualty evacuation
when they're going to be shooting at a
40 million dollar bird up in the air
you'll only land when it's a really
secure landing zone i'd give it about a
6.
you operate on a human time bomb while
your life flashes in front of you and
you promise god anything he wants it
will keep your patient from blowing up
in your face
he's doing a spinal anesthesia there i
like how he put the needle in and he's
injecting they did this in the korean
war back then they used a lot of
regional anesthesia
okay get it out of here
so he obviously got shot
in the buttock region pelvis region and
he's got a live ordinance in there so
this is a real scenario this happens i
think that's a rifle rifle grenade that
they shoot and usually that would not go
into them because this doesn't have a
sharp point or anything like that but
rocket propelled
rpgs
as they call it we did actually have
that during freedom war there's a
complete protocol about this usually
taken far away from the hospital in an
area that's fortified you take one
volunteer you say who volunteers to get
this medal because if you come out of it
alive you get a medal and then you try
to minimize the number of people that go
out there the chances of it going off if
it hasn't gone off at that point are
small but you want to minimize the risks
of doing things like that there was a
story i think in
2006 in afghanistan major john ho
west point grad doctor who had a guy
got a
rpg in his pelvis i think the grenade
portion wasn't there but the tail end of
it was sticking out of him they took a
six-man team and extracted it out so
that does happen my experience in the
military in the war was exactly like
mash the mud the dirt the people the
stories were exactly like mash and it
was just a ton of fun being out there
helping out the troops you get to help
out people who are injured out there so
that's the fun part the clothes that
they wear all that stuff is pretty
realistic i give this one a nine and a
half
yeah i hate this part if a guy at that
close range shoots you with an ak-47
with a 7.6 round that's gonna destroy
you but i mean it was really peripheral
so it somehow just got the most minor of
wounds but then they showed that picture
of the very distal portion of the right
lower lobe with a little air and what
they're trying to show is this thing
called the tension pneumothorax the lung
collapses to a little small thing and
then if the air continues to do it then
you get so much pressure that it pushes
on the heart and the heart doesn't fill
then your blood pressure falls and you
could die from that that's what they're
trying to to mimic here and this is
really rare
usually if you have a hole in the lung
it bubbles out so he's usually always
full of blood and blood is coming out
in a situation like that you would have
no breast sounds on one side and you
would have breast sounds on the other
side but we know that even with
stethoscopes when we do this it's very
misleading because when you put it on
the side that does have the tension you
can still hear the other side of the
lung so we have learned that that
physical exam is not very good
at that time during that war
they would not have this various needle
that special needle that he were using
in this scene there's a lot of problems
with that approach it is a sharp needle
it can cause a lot of injury to the
lungs and the way he turns it on he
doesn't really relieve it and
it wasn't the greatest
he had a through a stopcock so that's a
way that it has a valve it's not an
automatic valve it's something that you
have to open and close in one direction
or another to sit around with this
hardcore needle in your chest and you're
walking around completely awaken alert
and doing tension on it every few
minutes it's way far-fetched from a
medical perspective the way they did the
wounds and everything like that i give
it a two and a half
stay with me talk to you guys not
speaking what happens holy [ __ ] is that
kirk
there's some realism in there this is an
outpost this looks like army so army
italian base station army will usually
have a medic or they'll have a
physician's assistant usually with as
much webbing and stuff the unit that
they're in the housing unit and this is
paper thin so the bullets will go right
through there they should be a little
bit more
fortified with
the hesco barriers of dirt you notice
that the guy is bagging a guy because
he's not breathing well and they're
about to do cpr we don't do that out
there if they didn't sleep here that's
wasting time because they need blood
medevac will be here for a few hours
which means he needs fresh blood if he
wants to live this is the only thing we
can do we're not steroid we can't test
for disease but fresh blood is always
dude
gloves again with a bloody hands that's
not really realistic they have gloves at
this point when i went out there we
started doing this for the first time we
actually started to really use warm
fresh whole blood which is miraculous
it's unbelievably miraculous we can't do
that in the civilian world but we did
walking blood bank in my unit in a
ramadi charlie med
two surgeon shop we had about 60 70
medics with us as well
the base was about 600 people so we'd go
to the child hall and there would be a
guy that screams out walking blood bank
everybody would spit out their food go
line up at my medical company check
their dog tags they lay down on the
floor they would poke them
get a bag of blood we would do a little
test to see if they were compatible when
we used it so from that perspective it's
true there's a lot of little mistakes
that they made through here and in order
to dramatize it then they can get away
with it for most people but uh you know
you wouldn't be walking up to them
and giving them your blood standing up
and things like that at least they're
wearing the right uniform so i'll give
them seven
take the blessing all right
he happens to have miraculously one
bottle of plasma
and
rubber tubings that's what they use
bottle of plasma it wasn't clear it was
usually a little yellow you take your
blood and then if you put it into a
machine and spin it all the red cells
are heavy they go out to the outside and
that's your what we call your packed red
blood cells a thin layer of white cells
and the rest of the water which has
proteins in it is called plasma and it
has all these
proteins in it called factors which help
stop bleeding as well and it's a very
very good resuscitative tool much much
better than using the bags of iv the
saline and the lactated ringers that we
used in vietnam i like the idea that
they brought the plasma into it i'd give
this a six seven ep 80 over 60 pulse 112
severe burns distance shot
we got to take care of enemy combatants
we get soldier a and the guy who shot
soldier a we get to take care of both of
them we got to see take care of
civilians i took care of six-year-olds
with
big hunk of metal sticking out of her
neck
fortunately mr spinal cord burn ones
from explosions are common when you get
civilians they get burned military
people we didn't see a lot of burns
because again you're always in the
vehicles the setting is pretty realistic
for depending on where you are you know
they come in by stretchers like that
field hospital they have
you know lots and lots of doctors and
areas of triage and care versus a very
small area forward
left milligame's morphine
where she burned total body surface
burned
i estimate 45
the acting the the shaking the
convulsing i don't know what that was
all about he would see a person that's
moulaged with thoracic and frontal
extremity burns which is quite severe
probably closer to 80 90 percent but
then he's asking the other guy where his
burns is looking at the person and the
guy says legs well it's obvious to every
the viewer that's burned you know
everywhere the dialect was not really
realistic and uh not fun for me and
everything was very scripted i just
didn't enjoy this part of it at all
there was way to mess it up they messed
it up for some reason so i'd give it
about a five
just stay with me keep talking
keep making noises for me yeah
that's it
the medical care was good is exactly
what she should have done i was happy
with that she packed it she dressed it
she tried to tourniquet and sometimes
they still bleed out so that was
believable
normally you want to put tourniquet time
on the face and say when you put the
tourniquet on usually we'll do black
markers for that sharpies i want to know
whether that tourniquet has been on for
five minutes or 45 minutes if it's been
on for two hours you're going to have a
dead leg you got to cut off
[Music]
vietnam war huey helicopter from the
united states shows up and cranks her to
the top of that place and her coming up
there with the pressure on it that's
feasible and doable strategically just
didn't make a lot of sense i'm going to
say because you know the medical part
was was pretty decent i'd give it a five
six who i thought was more accurate the
top three i would say was saving private
ryan
uh hacksaw ridge and mash thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
on the link above